hello friends and welcome to the distant
past because today we're talking about
the past tense which refers to stuff
that has already happened there are many
ways to form the past tense but for
right now I just want to focus on the
basic version which is just adding Edie
so if you take word like walk as in I
walk to the store no not the store to
the moon I'm going to the moon on foot
try and stop me that's in the present
tense but if I wanted to put that in the
past I would say I walk I walked to the
moon I got very strong legs and good
shoes so this sentence is happening now
it's the present this sentence happened
earlier it's the past so the simplest
way to figure out whether or not
something is in the past tense or if you
want to put something in the past tense
is this thing this edy ending so you go
from walk to walked talked to talked
sneeze to sneezed jump to jumped and
open to opened so if it doesn't end with
an e Y add any D if it does end with an
e you just add the D that's how to form
the past tenth that's what the past
tense does it's stuff that's already
happened and most of the time when you
want to form the past tense out of a
word you just add II D you can learn
anything David